facing isolation due to covert
australia's prime minister made his
foreign policy address via social media
scott morrison confirmed that 70 million
dollars worth of humanitarian aid
ammunition and missiles had touched down
in europe destined for ukraine
during a phone conversation on saturday
he also offered president zielinski more
support if needed if there is further
effective support we can provide to
assist ukraine's efforts
we will
every day ukraine resists is a further
day of humiliation
for president putin and imposes a heavy
price on his illegal reckless and
callous acts of aggression
the australian prime minister denounced
what he described as russia's attempt to
reset world order he says the strategic
implications of this attack by president
putin stretch from europe to the
indo-pacific and warns that it could
embolden another authoritarian leader in
the region noting china's rapidly
expanding militarization in the south
china sea
the world has heard china's words about
its commitment to global peace and
respect for sovereignty and territorial
integrity and playing a positive role in
the international community for a very
long time now
so it's now up to china's and their
leaders at this hinge point of history
to demonstrate that these are more than
just words
but i fear the early signs are not good
china has embarked on one of the biggest
military spends in history growing its
air force and navy
australia the united states and the
united kingdom have boosted their
defence in the region under a trilateral
pact to ward off beijing's bid to
further expand in disputed areas and to
thwart its long-hard ambition to seize
taiwan
one thing we we know for certain is that
the military balance has shifted
dramatically over the last 20 years
much more in favor of china
so the the risk of china taking that
kind of action has i think grown
and we know that this is core business
for the communist party
australia has announced it will set up a
second submarine base to bolster its
regional defense capabilities british
american and australian nuclear-powered
subs purchased under the orcas
trilateral pact will be based here to
counter china's moves in the
indo-pacific construction of this space
will begin next year sarah clark al
jazeera brisbane australia